okay guys how's it gonna get sistene and
today we are unboxing something super
super super excited most of you guys
know my friend row from nerdy nummies
she does an incredible baking show we've
done so many collabs here on my channel
and on her channel and she has come out
with a baking line so without further
ado let's open oh my goodness there's so
many goodies in here maybe I'll put this
stuff
I am literally up against the wall right
now and I don't have any room can I
stick this okay I'll just put it off to
the side and I'll just get items oh this
is so cute
the first item out of the box is a poo
mold will you feast your little emoji
eyes on this I've made a lot of poo
themed things in my channel before but
this is amazing I've never made a 3d poo
mold you can make some brownies like
some poo ice cubes some poo candy this
is probably one of my favourite things
so far I don't even know this is the
thing until I had Metro I forget what we
were making I think we were making Lego
minifigure heads he had one of these and
she said it was her favorite thing now
she has her own version of a candy
melting pot oh my gosh oh I'm so
ecstatic right now so what's cool about
these is it will allow you to melt your
candy melts or your chocolate or
whatever it is that you're melting and
then once it's melted you can just
switch it to stay warm so you can just
kind of like set it aside and it won't
harden up once you're done you can let
your chocolate harden in here and then
you just flip this the opposite way and
just punch the chocolate out and you can
reuse it
I dig through all the pink confetti I've
got the items okay little half apron
this is so cute
you better believe I'm gonna be booty
shaking this all around my kitchen it's
even got some oven mitts to match oh my
gosh they're so cute and look at the
cute little tags like everything is so
cute look at these little teeny tiny
candies here's the little stars and the
little Lightning Bowl
these are little 8-bit hearts and
measuring cups
these are super nice quality this is
nicer than anything that I have in my
kitchen right now and they're colorful
too look at them it's got a cute little
grip right here with her little logo on
it and we've even got little measuring
spoons to match I love it they have like
this little ring because I feel like
every time I go to try to find a
measuring spoon they're everywhere look
at these little cookies the little
cookie cutters we're gonna look high and
a little 8-bit heart definitely want to
make a little 8-bit hearts this will be
really cool so I really want to start my
minecraft server up again and this is
gonna be absolutely perfect for that now
this is so nice it's like actually a
nice quality feel because there's some
little candy molds that are so flimsy
that if you put anything in it and you
try to pick it up it's just like folds
over is a really nice I can also use
this to make a Minecraft themed
something some diamonds oh my gosh I
think these might be some of my favorite
things these are a little cake testers
if you've ever made a cake before or the
best way to find out if the cake is done
is you shove like something in the
middle of it and if you pull whatever it
is out and there's like cake on it then
it's not done yet
he's got a little 8-bit heart and the
cute little smart cookie gal open them
up I feel bad opening and like ruining
her beautiful packaging
they're so cute I'm gonna be testing
cakes all day long thank you so much for
watching and a huge thank you to RO for
sending me a few of the items from her
baking line I'm so excited I'm so proud
of her make sure you guys go check out
her channel I will also put a link in
the description where you can check out
all of her baking items I'll see you
guys in my next video let me know what
you guys think I should make first I am
thinking I should probably make
something from the pool because this is
incredible
I'll see you guys later
[Music]
and now I can tell
it's
soon
are you sorry but you never can tell
we were dubbing forward to